(audience applauding and cheering)
- This is so fun.
- Have y'all ever met?
- We've never met.
- You never met?
- No.
I've seen you my whole life.
- Yeah, it's a pleasure.
- I feel like I know you.
- Same, I love your song.
- It looks like you called
each other, your color
palette, just saying.
- Yeah?
- Oh, thank you. (chuckles)
- Yes.
- So wait, you were also
in a classic TV show
when you were a kid that
I did not know about
until-
- Oh, my gosh.
- Before this interview,
we were diving into your past,
(Scott chuckles)
and I was like, "Wait, what?"
- I was like barely on it.
I was on "Barney" when I was a kid.
(audience laughing)
I was like-
(audience applauding)
- That's huge.
- (chuckles) It was huge,
but I was in like...
If you blink, you would've missed it.
- You were on it.
I wasn't on it.
(Scott laughs)
I wasn't cool.
I wasn't on any TV show.
- I was like,
Frisbee Thrower 1.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- In the background?
- And my mom got to be
on it with me.
They were like, "Do you wanna be in it?"
She's like, "Yeah."
And then I'm in the very
background and I'm just like.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
That's it.
- Your skills
(Scott laughs)
were (laughs) amazing in that.
- Yeah, they were blown away.
- Was it when like Selena
and all them were on it?
- Yeah, Selena was on it.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's crazy.
- So it was a pop icon episode,
apparently.
- Yeah.
(all laughing and clapping)
They didn't know it yet.
- They didn't know yet, but-
- But they had so many stars.
(Scott laughs)
Okay, so well, I know
you just got engaged.
- Yes.
- So congratulations.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- So how did y'all meet again?
- [Audience] Ah.
- [Wilmer] Ah, that's good.
- So cute.
- Ah, that's him.
How handsome is he?
- [Audience] Ah.
- [Kelly] And I love wherever you're at.
- [Scott] Oh, yeah, we were
wedding venue shopping.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was like,
well, you should pick there.
(Scott and audience laughing)
That's pretty, yeah.
- So we met at a mutual friend's
birthday party at a bar.
And then we hit it off, and
then I added him on Facebook.
This is how long ago it was.
I haven't used Facebook
in many years, but-
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- I just added him on Facebook, yeah.
- Isn't it weird how people date now?
Yeah.
- I know.
- I don't, but other people.
(all laughing)
I'm just like, that sounds exhausting.
- (laughs) You're like,
I have too many jobs.
- But it is weird,
like social media, how people meet.
Yeah, it just feels, I don't know,
I always get afraid that
you're gonna get catfished
or something.
- I know, I'm glad that
we met at a bar first
before the social media thing.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I'm scared
of that, too.
- Yeah.
- Catfishing-
- 'Cause people are liars.
- Watched too many episodes of that show.
- Yeah.
(Scott chuckles)
I've never watched one
'cause I'm already afraid.
- Yeah, no, it's terrifying.
- Yeah, it is terrifying.
(Scott laughs)
So wait, you were in
Meghan Trainor's last,
"Made You Look," the hit.
- Oh, yes, yeah.
- Yes.
(audience applauding and cheering)
I saw that and I was like,
wait, I didn't know y'all knew each other.
I had no idea.
- [Scott] Yeah, it was-
- [Kelly] How did that happen?
- It's a crazy story, actually.
We were acquaintances and we
texted sometimes and stuff.
- Yeah.
- And when we got engaged,
actually, Mark and I, she
texted me, "Congratulations."
- [Kelly] That's nice.
- And I was like, "Thank you so much.
What have you been up to?
I haven't talked to you in forever."
And she's like, "I'm working on music.
Do you want to hear anything?"
And I was like, "Yes, send everything."
She sent a couple songs, "Made
You Look" and "Bad For Me."
- Yeah.
- And I was like, "'Made
You Look' is a smash."
I was blown away.
She's amazing.
- Yeah.
- And then "Bad For Me,"
I've been producing and writing a lot,
and so I, for fun, just
like put a choir on it.
And I was like, "If you want
a choir version, here you go."
- [Kelly] I love that.
- And she loved it.
And she's like, "I'm gonna
use this for the album.
And also, come over tomorrow."
(Scott and audience laughing)
And so we started working
together a lot, and she's amazing.
- I love how organic that is, you know?
- Yeah.
- People didn't
put people together.
You just like, it happened to happen.
That's cool.
- Yeah, she's so hands-on
with the music she makes,
it's really amazing.
- Yeah.
- And I just really
respect that-
- And you're right,
it is a big hit,
(chuckles) "Made You Look."
- It is a smash.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you were right.
(Scott laughs)
I'm gonna send you
all my music
(Scott laughs)
(all laughing)
if you're the guy that knows.
- No, I'm not the guy that knows it all.
It was like so obviously
(Kelly laughs)
a smash. (laughs)
- Are you musical?
- I am musical.
- Yeah.
- Sing. (chuckles)
- All right.
- Obviously, by the game,
you know?
(all laughing)
- (claps) My specialty is '70s.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
Correct. That's really my sound.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So wait, is it true that
you're working on a musical?
- Oh, yeah.
I'm working on a musical.
- I'm excited about this.
Tell me about it.
- So it's about the Grim Reaper's retiring
and his daughter has to take over,
but she doesn't wanna be the Grim Reaper,
so she runs off with someone
she was supposed to take-
- Oh, cool.
(Kelly gasps)
- It's a really fun concept.
And we just did like a
real workshop in New York,
a union real thing with
actors and got to see it.
- Are you documenting all of it?
- Oh, yes.
- You need to do that. Okay.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] I'm like, this is huge.
- I'm so excited about it.
And I love the Broadway world.
- It's so hard.
I know friends that are doing show.
It's a process.
- [Scott] It takes forever.
- Yeah.
- And then once
you're done writing it,
then you have to do
workshops, workshop, workshop.
- Yeah.
- And then maybe previews,
and then maybe make it Broadway
if you're lucky.
- And then change it,
and then yeah.
and rip it apart, and change it around.
- Yeah.
- It is quite a journey.
It's gonna take years.
But it's been really fun
and it's been an exciting
creative project for me.
- Yeah, that's cool.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Thank you. Thanks, guys.
- Well, tell me about your single, "Mars."
- Oh, my gosh.
So this is my first
single ever as a solo act.
- [Kelly] Which is huge.
- It's huge.
It's really exciting for
me not only musically,
but also just as a person.
I've always been so
scared to put out a song.
And so I feel like this song just-
- That's crazy to me
'cause you're so gifted.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think that being in Pentatonix,
it's like your best friends
are up there with you
and you make stuff together,
and I was just so scared to be vulnerable
and tell my own story and be on my own.
And so this is, it's
about Mark, my fiance,
and just how much he
did for me personally,
and the insecurities I
went through in my 20s.
And then now, I feel
like I've got past it.
- Oh.
- And it all feels
like a beautiful moment.
- Well, first of all, congratulations.
- Oh, thank you.
(all laughing)
(audience applauding)
- For getting past it.
- It took a second.
- Yeah, (laughs) I was like,
(Scott laughs)
that-
- Whew.
- That should be celebrated.
(Scott laughs)
But also, that's amazing.